this is a catalytic decomposition of
hydroxide meet the kings of fail this is
definitely a display of how great it
would be to have a chemistry teacher for
a dad yes
Colorado chemistry tutor James King and
his family conduct homemade experiments
in their basement which don't always go
as planned I think these guys
underestimate the force of this reaction
they put plastic down everywhere but I
don't think but this is gonna spray all
over the ceiling but how did the King
family create a fantastic foaming fiasco
the ingredients they've got in the
bottle are hydrogen peroxide and
washing-up liquid now hydrogen peroxide
if it's concentrated you can use it as
rocket fuel rohan adds an extra special
ingredient this is potassium iodide and
this acts as a catalyst now catalyst is
something that speeds up the reaction
without really getting used up over time
hydrogen peroxide will very slowly
decompose into water and oxygen gas
however the addition of the catalyst
reduces the amount of energy that is
needed for this reaction to take place
we're able to decompose all the hydrogen
peroxide in a very short space of time
so it seems the Kings have
underestimated the power of the catalyst
this reaction produces loads of oxygen
which is all caught up in bubbles made
out of the washing up liquid this
generates also a lot of pressure inside
the bottle which is why we see this foam
shoots out of the top and onto the
ceiling
remember these kings have a chemist in
the family so don't try this at home